We are hosting our first ever,
live-streamed graduate Q&A tonight.
We are going be talking about, um,
for those of you that aren't familiar with our programs,
our graduate certificate portfolios.
So, we offer a number of courses in school of engineering at Stanford,
online and remotely for working professionals to take,
to earn graduate credit and a grade and eventually,
under graduate certificate or maybe even transfer
and move on to a master's degree at Stanford in the future.
So, we have two of our great students here tonight,
who are gracious enough to share their time with us,
and share their experience,
um, being working professionals,
taking these courses, and just share,
you know, what do they plan to do with it?
What are their expense- experience from like being an online student.
Um, as a- just reminder to those of you who are remote right now,
we're using Poll Everywhere,
which is like a polling service.
There's a link in the YouTube description,
and for those of you here, I wrote it up on the whiteboard.
Um, you can go and submit questions,
you can up-vote questions that you really wanna hear about,
and we'll try our best to kinda cover everything that people wanna know.
Um, so, why don't we start with just having each of you introduce yourselves,
where you currently work,
and what some of the coursework you've completed through us has been? Yeah.
Sure, I can go first.
Yeah. You can go.
Hey everybody. So, my name is Utkarsh.
Uh, well, I work locally. I work in Palo Alto.
I work for a startup,
it's a self-made startup not too far from here.
I work as a technical director there of AI.
So, the coursework, you know,
has been following that trajectories,
I've been uh, you know,
with the program for almost a year now, a year and a half, and uh,
taken a bunch of courses in AI,
um, 224N and 231N.
And then right now, I'm enrolled in 221 which
is the Artificial Intelligence principles and techniques.
So, pretty much the courses have been geared to what I, you know,
do at work and even what I want to do at work before I
started this line of- of- of endeavor.
So, that's been my journey so far and,
you know, it's pretty exciting so far.
[LAUGHTER]
Hello. My names Alex Kim.
Uh, I work in Sunnyvale for a credit union as a Compliance Manager.
So, I'm always been the non-tech person in my classroom,
[LAUGHTER] in all my classes.
Uh, I've taken about nine classes,
uh, through SCPD, uh,
from stats, international security,
and somewhat MSE E-courses.
Management Science and Engineering.
Yes.
MS and E.
Yes. Um yeah.
Yeah. So, maybe as just like a follow-up question.
What motivated you to start taking coursework through SCPD?
Yeah, I guess, um,
I always wanted to do my master's, right?
I mean- but before I actually work I,
you know, jumped into, you know,
that commitment of, you know, actually doing a masters,
I want to see what graduate courses were like.
So, I think SCPD gave that venue, you know,
that- that avenue to explore,
it's kind of almost like test drive some of these, uh,
these courses because before,
you know, committing full time into it.
And especially, I think, uh,
being a full-time professional,
uh, you know, having like,
you know, 60-80 hour work weeks right.
Uh, you always have this, uh,
um, the scare if you can, you know,
really commit that time and, you know,
dedication to committing and, you know, fulfilling, ah,
a full-time master's or even a part-time masters.
So, I think this was, ah, this was a good opportunity to just ge- get that,
um, get that experience and- and just
to try it out for myself, if that's something I wanted to do.
So, and I think that- that the program just fit in.
I mean, it just, ah, worked, ah,
to my aspirations and that's was
the primary motivation to- to start something like this. Yeah.
Okay.
For me, I started out, ah,
because I want to compliment continuing education for my work.
So, I started- ah, I used to work for
regulatory agency and I wanted to learn more about financial models.
So, I started with taking a stats course that covers financial models.
And then, once I took that course,
I just kind of looked at the menu of offering and saw like
how many great courses and then at the faculties that SCPD offers.
So, I ventured out to international security programs because I always had,
you know, interest in international affairs,
and- and I wanted to learn more, and,
you know, was- this was a perfect opportunity to do that where you get to listen to, um,
all the renowned faculties,
including former Deputy Director of
National Intelligence and from ambassadors from Russia and Afghanistan.
So, and I- and then I think I venture into what he was saying.
So, and what more can I do here?
And next thing was a natural progression was going into masters.
And before I come in I wanted to try it out,
so I started taking MSE courses to see if it's a good fit for me and so far,
it's been, and I actually applied for next year.
Oh, awesome. That's- that's a great follow-up question.
So, now that you've been taking courses,
how has this affected kind of your career goals or your academic goals?
Okay, take it.
Okay. Well, I think one thing,
it benefit me for my career wise.
As I actually tried to apply to some of the things I learned on class like,
for instance, like I took class management course and, uh,
during the class, we learn the real bounding principles and
actually try to learn more about that lit-
a little bit more about and actually tried to apply that in my job.
So, and seeing how I could
apply like what I'm actually learning from classroom to my work,
you know, and seeing more opportunities to do that to this class where the program.
Yeah.
Yeah. I'm gonna quote a little bit of what you said because, um,
I think because I have been in the industry for a decade and, you know,
a lot of what, you know,
I've learned is, you know, what I've used before.
You know, some of these courses as well, but I think, um,
the differentiating factors, you know,
um, the- the field changes, the field evolves, right?
Any field of engineering or science,
it keeps evolving and I think, ah,
being connected to- to the latest and greatest that's happening in- in academia
and bringing that back to the industry is- is
extremely critical especially in these times and ages where,
you know, research makes it so fast from lab to production.
So, I think, um, one of the most lucrative factors of,
you know, getting con- connected back to academia was in a while.
You know, being in a- in a profession
which requires you to be on the bleeding edge of technology,
but how do you- how do you, you know,
instrument yourself back into that framework of,
you know, learning an application.
So, I think, um, you know,
having what the- what- essentially,
I noticed in terms of, you know,
my career goals was,
you have the- the fundamentals are all, you know,
the- the same, but what- what really advances you
is the connections that you make in the- both, you know,
in academia and then through that- through that exposure,
you know, the literature,
the- the science that you get exposed to.
And I've seen that a lot of work you know,
that- that I've- that I've been exposed to over
the years has translated back to- to the work- workplace,
and so we've been able to connect, you know
Research to actual application which has been very,
yes, it's been very beneficial.
That's awesome. And you also, I think told,
me earlier that you are also applying to a master's program now at Stanford.
That's right. That's right.
So, now both of you are applying at this point.
Yes, yes.
That's awesome. So just to give some context for people who
don't really understand the connection between these two programs,
all the courses you take in a graduate certificate,
you can transfer up to 18 units of that coursework to a master's program at Stanford,
if you are admitted,
if you apply and are admitted to a program.
So this is a really great example for both of them of
how they've taken courses and it kind of
inspired them to maybe apply to actually
pursue a degree and now they can actually take the coursework,
if they're admitted, and transfer it toward
their degree and be kind of ahead in completing it.
And maybe another great segue to talk about,
once you are in these courses,
what was it like balancing work and studying?
Because I think that's the thing most people are concerned
about is how I'm gonna go back to school and maintain my job.
Yeah, and I think that's a good question,
and it's- there's no easy answer to that.
Yeah. [LAUGHTER]
Because I think, it's, yeah,
I mean for- I think initially it's like anything, really.
I mean, it's, it's- you have to,
you know, invest a lot at the start.
I mean it takes a little bit of getting used to in,
in managing- I don't say managing time is more like managing priorities,
because, you know, you have a limited time range,
so how do you fit your priorities in that time?
So, I had- you know, you have to really balance stuff.
So yes, you know,
initially you have to give up a little bit of your weekends.
You know, you have to, um,
maybe put in some extra effort after work and, you know,
just I guess go through the- go through the motions
until you get to a place where you know you're now more,
uh, you know, I guess efficient and adaptive to the coursework.
So the courseworks essentially,
I think, are beautifully designed because, you know,
everything that is required for the coursework is a, available online.
So a person like me,
you know, who- so, initially,
now I work very close to school,
but for the first year,
I was almost like 25 miles away from school.
So it was very hard to, you know,
come in all the time, right?
So it's, it's really- I think the way these courses are structured is,
you know, most of the collaboration can happen online,
and that's helped a lot.
I mean, especially the- even just the simple things like the quality of the video,
right, and the actual engagement in- thereof, so that that has helped.
But also, you know, the other forums.
Like, I think, the, the meetings.
Or Piazza.
The Piazza.
Yeah.
Piazza is really good actually.
You can- I mean,
I've never had my question
not answered like within the first couple of hours of posting it,
so I think somebody's always on it.
So, I think for the most part if you really want to make it work, you know you can.
It's just, um, going to initial hurdle of,
you know, getting things into motion.
Yeah. You have anything to add on that?
I mean, like you said, the technology makes it very
interactive even though it's an online class like Piazza or,
um, those other website that the faculty use, the TAs use.
You can interact with different students,
you can interact with different students through Google Plus, Google Hangouts, Skype.
I've done study groups with people in France and,
I mean, we tried to make it work.
So I think because the way SCPD runs a program,
it makes it work for you so that- and,and also make it meaningful at the same time.
And as far as the time management for me was I tried to, um,
select a course that I really wanted to learn,
not something that I will have to take.
So if you are doing something you really like,
you just make time to do it so,
um, because- I think that's why I did it.
Yeah, yeah. What- you know,
you're talking about some of the great parts of remote learning.
What has been a challenge in being a remote student?
I guess for me is not being able to interact at live time.
Yeah.
So, um, but I think recently a lot of the TA started, um,
office hours using Google Hangout or Skype,
so they're available each week to actually interact with you, uh,
through Sky- like face- like,
face chatting, and things like that.
So, it's been- that's been helpful.
And the benefit of me being- living close by,
I actually attend classes when I can, um,
so I can actually interact with,
um, TAs and then the faculties.
Yeah. I think for me, uh,
and this is more than me, because,
uh, just having the time to make it
to study sessions and groups- I mean although, you know,
it's been easy to form groups,
but just to keep up to,
you know, coming to campus and,
you know- or maybe somewhere to form- I mean,
we've had online- online, you know,
meetings and collaborations, which is good,
but I think, um, just being in here in person,
sometimes you know, I have to wait like maybe
a couple of days to get the answer which I could have probably gotten right there.
So yeah, and I think asking
the professor a question during an online session is not possible so [LAUGHTER].
Yeah, unfortunately not yet.
We've just started piloting technology where we can live stream the courses,
but that doesn't enable live participation.
Right.
Um, I mean, even as we're seeing now,
this is us trying to do live participation,
and even that's not as- as great as
it is if you're physically here to raise your hand, right?
So, it's something we're working on, but- but
you are right like that can definitely be a challenge.
Um, what are some tips you would give to
a new student to be successful in their first course?
I think, um, I would resound what you said- what he said,
because I think one of
the most important thing to be successful is to really enjoy what you're doing, right?
So most people, I am assuming ,
who take a SCPD or,
you know, respective courses,
they really to- they're really either are working
in that field that they're taking to study them or want to work,
right, or some combination thereof.
So I think it's very important to,
to tie your why to what you're doing,
because otherwise it really becomes- really becomes a drag, right?
So, please- personally for me,
I wanted to make sure that, you know,
the- so my courses align really well with what I do so,
I think it just becomes an extension of work in that way but
something that I want to work on kind of thing versus what you have to do at work, so.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah, so I think that's number one to be,
you know, I guess, be successful.
I mean there's so many other things.
But I guess- also you know,
just- when I'm trying to,
you know, keep up with the coursework, I mean,
just make sure that you participate.
I think participation is key in, in,
in discussions and forums,
and then some of the- in Piazza.
Piazza is really awesome if you use it really well.
So, yeah, those are some of the starter tips,
and if I remember more,
I will think of that. Yeah.
Yeah, anything that you want to add?
Well, I mean, like he said, like,
I guess try to find passion in learning at Stanford through the course offerings.
Um, and then another thing
is always form a study group,
because it helped me a lot.
I'm a business major with no math background or net- no tech background.
So, it has been especially challenging for me taking some of the courses
with taking advanced statistics course or programming courses.
So the study group have helped me greatly getting,
one, learning from bouncing off each other and also getting a decent grade.
Yeah. What has been one of the best parts of taking courses through SCPD?
I guess the people you meet, um,
like the faculties you meet and then the people you get to interact with.
Like, everybody's smarter than me,
and where do you get to meet people like that,
or interact with people who are much smarter than you and,
and also speak intelligently?
[LAUGHTER]
Can I say two best parts.
Yeah, of course. Yes.
[LAUGHTER] I think the first is the faculty.
I mean, you are exposed to some really legends in the industry.
I mean you name the course, right?
I mean, you're talking about folks like [inaudible] ,
you know Eichler publications and they are,
like, on the key notes of- like one of the most inspiring,
you know, speeches, you know, of your domain.
So that's- that's really good.
And having access to those people, like,
you could literally walk up to them and ask them a question, right?
I mean that's, that's really,
um, you know, when you're in like a TA session or something.
So that's been really encouraging and just getting, you know, feedback on.
And then I think the TA group is really awesome.
They- they do a really hard work and help support you.
Um, apart from that,
I think one really good part I like about SCPD is the collaboration in the projects
because those are like really- you can collaborate with Stanford students full-time,
and then, you know, two or three [inaudible] sessions and projects,
and that you've really worked with a group here and,
you know, you make something of value.
And, and so, many times those turn into, like,
publications or project, you know,
reports that are really useful there as well.
So, I think- I loved the projects that we did as part of SCPD.
Awesome! How does a student make
a successful connection with a course teaching team while studying remotely?
Just participate in the office hours they're available.
Yeah. Yeah, I think office hours are a key.
I mean, if you can come in per- personally, that's awesome.
If not, you know, there is like- at least for my course,
there's like a weekly office hour that- for SCPD students,
which is- which is equally engaging and the technology is good.
You have, uh, I forget the name of that queuing system,
but there's, like, really- you don't have to,
like, hang up on the line,
you can just put in your queue and you know,
your- you can- yeah,
it's just really nice that technology supports, you know,
this collaboration, the Skype videos and Google bits and all that.
But beyond that I think,
also, uh, connecting with as many, I guess,
um camp- on-campus students helps,
because then you're building those connections and, you know,
you're doing projects together or reports together,
uh, even study groups together.
Have you been able to maintain any of those connections you've made with the students?
Yeah. Yes, absolutely. Actually, um,
pretty much through every course that I've done so far, you know,
we had been keeping in touch.
And in one of the projects we are actually actively collaborating,
this is almost a year after the course ended.
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah. How about you?
Have you have been able to keep in touch?
Yes, they are my LinkedIn friends.
[LAUGHTER] And some Facebook friends.
There you go, networking opportunities.
Um, what's something you wish you'd known before you started taking courses through SCPD?
Workload.
So- so, to be really honest, right?
So some of the courses that you're talking about this offline as well,
some of the courses are intense, right?
And then you know, um,
they all like 45 units,
but it really- it's- the math doesn't work directly, right?
I mean, in some courses,
they're manageable and you can really get through them,
you know, along with, you know, and expect,
what you expect in terms of putting in an hours per weekly but,
some ones are, you know,
like require almost one and half times the effort which- which kinda,
you know, close out some of your- some of your calculations.
So, I think, um,
one of the things, you know,
would be to, you know, kinda just go to the syllabus and, you know,
make sure that you know, you get something that
you can manage with your current workload.
Yeah.
I think that will definitely help,
you know, figure some of the, at least, join. Yeah.
I agree. I mean,
this is not a Stanford extension like UCLA extension [LAUGHTER].
Right.
You are- you have opportunity to take classes with full-time graduate students.
So, they are intense, I mean, as for me,
majority of the classes were intense, uh,
because I didn't have math or tech background.
But again, there's- other students help and faculty's help.
Um, as long as you do your work,
the carving is great.
So, as long as you do your work you're gonna get your grade.
So, there you go. [LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Um, maybe speaking just thinking
about your work experience, your professional experience,
how have your companies that you've been at
valued this certificate or this course work as opposed to,
you know, just coming in with a master's degree,
um, and, you know,
do you think it makes a difference at all?
I think, um, a lot of employers are very supportive of this thing.
So, I've been working, I've looked at a lot of big corporations now at Startup.
So, um, throughout the course work I think,
you know, in terms of supporting financially,
these employers have supported the- the cost of
the course and I think we have- SCPD has partnerships too with-
Yes, yeah, we have certain partnerships and- and depending on the billing situation,
if you are getting some sort of employer-based funding,
we're very flexible with helping, like,
support that mode of payment, like,
we don't require only your credit card if you have a voucher
or a company is gonna send a check for you, you know,
were very accommodating to that because we do recognize that people are getting
tuition sponsorship from different modes than just their own personal- personal income.
Right. So, yes. I guess it's, uh,
it's been supportive and I think,
uh, also I think the value you bring back from these courses translates to, I mean,
I don't know does it really hard, you know,
I guess co-relation there but I think it just helps you in terms of,
you know, advancing your career,
I mean, uh, um, in terms of, you know,
just getting better rules at- at work,
you know, better projects,
maybe your promotion, what have you, I don't know.
But, uh, yeah. I think, for sure,
I think it- it helps get our self confidence too.
For me, you know,
I didn't know, you know,
they're having this certificate program when your resume would actually help you,
um, because I've recently changed my job,
and through that process,
one thing I noticed was
they don't care whether it says master's program or certificate program,
they only look at Stanford's name and that goes a long way.
And- and I- I- I actually noticed that and I was kinda surprised that they actually,
"Oh, you went to Stanford."
Well, it's a certificate program but well,
doesn't know you went to Stanford.
So- so I think it does carry weight, um, career wise.
I mean, I don't think either of you in our time talking have
talked about making any drastic career shift while doing these- these programs.
But do you think, you know,
if you were trying to kinda change your specialization or what you're doing,
you could leverage the specific coursework you took to do that?
I mean, if you combine your experience and coursework here,
I think definitely will help you to go to the route,
what- whichever route you would take as they recognize an end,
that just keeps the credibility I think.
Yeah. Yeah. I think, uh,
it's been a little bit more,
I guess, concrete in my case because, you know,
especially in the- in the ifield,
I mean, a lot of work,
uh, is required in the market out there is- is covered in this courseworks, right?
So, I think, um,
it's more to, I guess, uh,
it was a direct correlation of having some of these courses on your- on your resume,
uh, to, you know,
just- like its having a better opportunity.
So, uh, I think it depends on, you know,
what the- uh, I guess the trajectory of your career is.
But I think in- in some cases,
I think these- these directly correlate.
Yeah. Um, but we did get a question kind of
around what is the average class size or the amount of students
we have every- every quarter and I- I
can speak just from an administrative side, you know.
I would say autumn and winter quarters are
our biggest but we're usually getting, you know,
800 to a thousand students remote, uh,
each quarter, and but that doesn't even include
the on-campus enrollment with all the matriculating students.
So, I'm kinda curious in your experience uh,
definitely for you being in the larger CS classes has that bad, I mean,
is there any like pros and cons to that or what
is your experience then being in this large classes,
and maybe if you've been in smaller ones,
you can speak to maybe the difference of that.
Yeah. I think on an average,
my class size has been 800.
Yeah. [LAUGHTER].
So, it's- it's definitely a huge- huge class size.
I know necessarily if it,
uh, if it really makes, um,
any- any difference because, you know,
at the end of the day, you know,
being a remote student, right, I think, uh,
you- you still have the- the access to the material,
you know, the- the same way, so and, uh,
you know for- I think it's a little bit better for benef- for a SCPD students because,
you know, I think you have your own office hours which is,-
Yeah.
-you know, not that- that huge rate.
Um, so, I don't know that I have really necessarily faced any- any cons.
As a matter of fact, you know, for even the midterms, you- you know,
initially I did not know that I had to do an exam monitor but I have
all take- I always taken my midterms on campus which is,
uh, which is good because, you know, it's- it's for
me it's better taking class than, you know, do it-
Yeah.
-at home. So, yeah,
I don't think it's mattered that much,
at least in my case.
Me, I've taken courses where I was one of
300 and most students have taken other courses where I was one of two remote student.
[LAUGHTER] So, in a smaller setting,
you know, the professors actually interact with you,
they know you by first-name basis and we
interact on Piazza and they usually respond right away.
So, you have better interaction.
In larger classroom, you have larger pool of
people you can be accrued to come build your study group.
So, a lot of time, in those classes,
we normally start with like 20 people in a study group and then at the end,
are left with maybe five.
[LAUGHTER] But throughout the process,
you're- you're getting help from all those people so.
And I think one thing I notice with Stanford classes,
they- they set you up to work in team.
[LAUGHTER] They- they enforce you to work in the team
outside classroom and sometimes you learn more from, uh,
the study group than in classroom,
because sometimes I think it's designed that way,
but I don't know, but at sometime it came up [LAUGHTER] that way.
Yeah, that's great. Um, we had one question that just came through that I can take.
It was about many non-CS classes still require a programming background of some kind.
So, for those of us without that background,
how- how do we get that, is that something we offer?
We do offer some lower-level CS courses,
CS 106A and 106B which are like the introductory programming courses.
We've also introduced a few self-paced non-credit courses
that are like intro to data science,
like in R course, Python course.
Um, so those are some options,
I- I would say that, uh,
the departments are also very open to other online courses that you're doing at home,
if that's something that works better for you to
kind of supplement this prerequisite knowledge.
They just look to see the you have a certificate or
something showing that you actually did the work.
Um, so definitely, don't be prohibited from applying in the future.
You know, you- you're welcome to email us and we can take
a look at your transcripts and- and work with the departments and say,
"Okay, you wouldn't be approved right now.
But if you did this and this,
and got X grade or showed this certificate,
we can definitely, you know,
approve you to take the course."
So, you know, don't feel discouraged just because it seems like there's a lot of
engineering courses that require higher-level prerequisites,
there's still a lot of ways that you can still get that and we'll try to
support you to still end up in the course you want to be in.
Um, so definitely, just always communicate with us and we can- we can help along the way.
Um, maybe as like another question.
What is your- have you noticed that now since you live in the area,
you're mostly trying to come to class to meet with TA's or professors,
um, and have you ever like you said,
you were 25 miles away when you first started.
Right.
Did you take your classes exclusively online
and was that- how was that experience just being purely online?
Yeah. The first, I guess,
the first- first course was exclusively online and I think,
uh, I mean, you- you definitely, I mean,
I personally have benefited a lot coming to campus because now that
I'm closer in it just helps build connections with people and,
you know, folks that you work on a project basis or a classroom basis,
even study sessions for that matter.
But even taking exclusively online, I think,
uh, it's- it's a different experience.
I mean, you think you gear yourself to,
you know, address the core folk in that sense.
So, you know, just,
uh, one thing about taking classes online, right,
is that you can actually pause and play the video when you want to,
which is- which is, you know, you can't do that in the class.
So, I- I see myself, you know,
myself going back and forth and, you know,
taking a lot more notes, right?
[LAUGHTER] I'm doing it online versus,
uh, kinda, you know, being here.
But again, I think it's just a different experience.
So, I think, it's really hard to quantify which one is better but I think,
uh, at the end of the day, I think,
uh, you know, what you- what you gain from,
you know, I- I guess from the- from both of them is just different.
So, I know if I prefer one versus the other.
Yeah.
But, yes, to answer your question I do see
myself coming to campus more often now that I'm in the area.
Yeah.
Yeah but there's nothing to do with,
you know, if it's more better of it.
Yeah. And definitely all of these courses can be done completely remotely.
Yeah.
I think that was part of the point of this event-
Right.
-is to show that-
Exactly.
-you know, you can do this at a distance and
still get access to all of the great benefits of these-
Right.
-Stanford courses have to offer.
Um, I don't know if have you anything to add to that either?
Um, I think it's beneficial to have that option to come but there's pros and cons.
You said like math intensive courses,
I get to pause the video,
take nowhere to all the students
in class that I see then struggling [LAUGHTER] to take note.
Um, so to being able and I see a lot of full time students now have access to the SCPD,
uh, recording, so then I see them la- uh,
using that as well for their benefits,
it's going back with being able to just go back and
listen again and for preparing for midterm or final,
you can go back to the lecture and just listen to that again, Um,
and I- I travel a lot so I've lots of lectures on plane,
at the airport or,
you know, in Uber, so [LAUGHTER].
Things like so th- the online class
setting kind of gives you the flexibility so
it's beneficial for people who's working [OVERLAPPING]. Yeah.
Yeah, and have eight hours.
What are like some just tips, I mean,
you've obviously talked about using the recordings
and pausing them and taking better notes as helpful.
Is there any other just study tips that you would
say to someone taking one of these courses?
I think one of the things that helped me initially was,
you know, just volunteer to be a note-taker.
That was good because, you know,
you kind of force yourself to be disciplined in- in terms of taking notes and,
you know, just being more involved with the curriculum.
So, you know, once you do that it kinda- that kinda helped me to start [OVERLAPPING].
So if saying somebody wants to be a note-taker,
it just help them to be more involved with the program initially.
Now, I have not done it for
the last two courses but I think that was one good experience.
Um, the other tips I guess, uh,
I think the office hours are under emphasized,
so I am gonna re-emphasize that [LAUGHTER] and I think they're really,
really beneficial and coming back to,
you know, just getting.
I think it just, sometimes,
you know, being a remote student,
you're working through problems and you know,
it's just let's say it's a math problem or wha- what have you,
you just get stuck in a loop and, you know,
you keep attempting it and, you know,
maybe you just end up more, spending more time than you want to.
You just bringing that back to office hours or,
you know, remotely collaborating helps.
I think is having and building as many connections has,
has really been, you know, one of the success factors of,
you know, this whole program.
Also unless you're Stephen Hawking's [LAUGHTER] If you don't do office hours,
if you don't do study group,
if you don't ask a lot of questions,
it's hard to succeed.
I mean, you know,
I said they curve the grades,
so I think getting a B is
pretty easy as long as you do the work but getting an A is extremely hard.
So, you have to do,
push yourself to get an A or
A plus in all these classes so if you don't do all those three,
you know, then you- you will,
it will be hard to be successful in these classes.
It's good to know. That's real- real talk right there.
Um, I'm gonna take you guys back to when you were
first deciding [NOISE] to apply to do coursework.
What was the application experience like?
Any, any pain points or any tips for
students that you would give if you wanna start applying for one or quarter?
Yeah, I guess for me, even before,
I think before I decided to go into like a more graduate program,
I took a few courses that were unrelated to the current,
you know, program that I am doing,
that is some business courses [OVERLAPPING] and stuff.
So, that was, that was pretty straightforward.
I mean, I think it was just going to the website and and applying it.
I'm not sure if this was true for SCPD, probably for SCPD. [OVERLAPPING].
It's like a professional certificate?
Yes, exactly.
Yeah.
So, I think that kinda gave a little bit of a,
I guess, a teaser as to, you know,
how things are and those were really good courses as well probably one to two units max.
Yeah.
But then I think, when I finally decided to,
you know, be serious and go,
you know to specific, er, program,
I think, um, you know,
it was pretty I think streamlined.
I mean, it was essentially,
um, going to the website getting information.
I think corresponding with the SCPD staff was really helpful because,
you know, they were very responsive.
I mean, usually an email you wait for a week or
something before you get a respond but I was pretty happy about
the response time and in general the- the responsiveness of the, of the folks.
And then I think, um,
just in terms of eligibility it was
just a matter of submitting your transcripts and, you know,
a few more questions and, you know,
I think it was not that hard, it's pretty straightforward.
So, the- yeah I think it was,
you know, more or less seamless to, to begin with.
And did you feel that way even once you were approved to take your first course?
Did you feel like the transition into your class and
all the different systems and accounts that Stanford has? How was that experience?
Yeah, I think it took a little bit to get used to that.
I mean, especially, you know,
I kinda like miss initially when I wanted to certain
course but then I kind of vaguely like a week after it was announced and it was gone.
So, you know, you gotta be 10 top of
your registrations because some of these courses are so popular.
You know, you probably in a week's time they all fall. Right? [OVERLAPPING]
Yeah.
And you're on the wait list.
Yeah. And I would say particularly with
your experience with artificial intelligence courses,
[OVERLAPPING] those tend to be the ones that fill up within the first week,
first few days of enrollment,
um, depending on what they are.
So, I would definitely say,
you know, if there's a course that, you know,
you wanna take, don't hesitate, submit the application,
enroll, um, or just, you know,
call us and let us know and we can reiterate please enroll like,
like get this done.
Um, because then we have exactly what happened to you.
We have people who are like, "Well I wanna take this course and now it's
full and it's online there's unlimited seats."
Right? And it's like, "Well, no someone has to grade."
[LAUGHTER] So, yeah, definitely I would echo everything you've said.
Right. And I think the good part is there's also like a,
you know, you can try the course and if you change your mind,
you can always, you know, figured out you know what,
you know, if you want to take another course or something so that's an option too.
Yeah.
Um, but I think beyond that you got into systems and stuff I think,
um, I think Piazza was pretty helpful.
Yeah, getting on it was just signing up.
So, yeah, I don't think there was any major issues I think we're just
going a little bit back and forth with the staff to clarify some of the questions.
So I'm glad that there's somebody who's, you know,
dedicated to this function so that you don't have figure out everything yourself.
Yeah. Now, you like a few questions in there but just to start
again what was your application and enrollment process like? [LAUGHTER]
So, as far as application process that it was pretty
much harder it's still Stanford, right?
And I applied to provide a transcript, right?
To write a short essay.
That's right.
And within an hours like, "Hey,
your'e approved." Is that easy.
Okay. It's not in hours,
I think. [OVERLAPPING] [APPLAUSE].
I mean, it was pretty fast.
It was- it is faster. [LAUGHTER]
Um, I- I thought it was gonna be
the reviewing application and going through different process but it was,
it was matter of hours or even days.
Um, I've got approval and as far as prerequisite,
as a business major, I didn't meet any prerequisite, you know.
Business majors, so you just need to add and subtract.
Right? [LAUGHTER] I didn't have to do with calculus
or anything like that so I had to do all the calculus,
all the computer programming, um, prerequisite.
And they are very helpful like I just
found this unknowns community colleges down south and I start taking courses.
I provided the coursework to this PD and they said, "Yes, that's fine."
And it was just, you know, same day.
It's like, "Okay, you can take that we'll accept it."
And then they accepted everything,
and I was able to meet all the prerequisite to take some of the courses.
And as far as the technologies,
I think that's where also where
the Interacting with TAs and students is important because,
where like at first they're like,
they're drawing these, um,
okay this is on Canvas and this is on Piazza so it was Canvas and Piazza.
But it's that you- you got to interact with people to
find out where the Canvas- what is Canvas and how to use it.
And what's Piazza and wha- how to use Piazza, you know.
Because there's no manual to use it,
you just have to learn it on your own and,
and everybody's helpful you just have to ask the question.
Yeah, yeah. And I would say,
you know, to echo I mean,
I guess this makes me look bias but I would say we have a good response time to email.
[OVERLAPPING] So, if you're having any confusion
about our application, our enrollment system,
or you know, once you're in a course where- what is Canvas? What is Piazza?
How do I get my Stanford email, you know,
those are all things that our team is here to do.
Um, I answer a lot of those emails every day.
So, we're definitely trying to make it as easy a process as possible,
especially because you are remote you can't just
show up to your Adviser or to your Professor and say,
I don't understand what's going on.
Um, so we try to be really mindful of that in our response times.
And, uh, just to also reiterate about the application process.
We try to keep it as simple as possible
yes these are Stanford courses but unlike applying to a master's program, you know,
if you're qualified to take the course and you've- you've enrolled
on time and sent the application and the transcripts.
You'll most likely be approved.
The departments just wanna make sure qualified people are in there,
but they're not like we only admit 30 percent, you know.
Um, and, and we try to get you answers as fast as possible,
it usually takes a few weeks from when you apply and enroll.
And, and I'll mention this again at the end of
the presentation by winter quarter enrollment is open so if you know,
this presentation sold you,
you can just get right into it and apply and probably enroll by the end of this week,
that's how easy it is.
So, um, yeah definitely I'd echo that.
We try to keep it as simple as possible and,
and also improve our communication around all the different platforms and systems,
because that is something we recognize can be a little confusing for
a new student or someone that hasn't been in college for a while.
Um, so we got a new question that is
asking how you decided to take courses here at Stanford,
rather than another online platform like Coursera or Udacity or things like that.
Yeah, I think that's a- that's a very good question.
Um, I mean, I did take online courses like Udacity or Coursera.
But I think personally, what I've felt with online courses is,
um, I personally cannot find myself to commit to them.
Um, maybe it's a force function, maybe it's Stanford,
maybe it's the, you know,
the- the association of folks around here,
maybe it's the group study.
Um, I personally I am not a big fan of,
you know, what do you call them,
there's a nice acronym.
Self-paced? MOOCS?
MOOCS! Yeah.
Yeah. So, yeah, I mean,
uh, I mean maybe it's, uh,
maybe it's a personal thing but, uh,
for me to succeed,
uh, and be focused on, you know,
provide, you know, my best I think I need to
be involved with a group of people who I can see,
you know, and- and know an- and I think some to provides you kinda like all of that.
But, uh, but like,
you know, the flexibility of doing it when you want to do it,
which is- which is, I mean,
pretty- which is very hard to find in- in- in online courses.
So, um, yeah.
Also the- just-just- you know,
the- I think the best part I like about this course is,
your schedule is aligned with the- with the full time students, so that way,
you know, you have- you're now accountable to not just,
you know, your- yourself but to the group that you're working with.
So, it's- it's time-bounded and, you know,
for some of the online courses even though they are time bounded,
just doesn't work the same way.
Yeah.
What about you?
For me it's like whether you take a course at Stanford or MOOC or Coursera, take- yet,
it still commit your time to do it and I
guess you have to think about what's more meaningful to you.
And the- just by looking at the people
the Stanford program attracts and then the faculty's they offer,
like where do you go and learn about US-Russia relationship,
uh, from a former ambassador of- to Russia, right?
[LAUGHTER] So, and then is- that list goes on and on.
Right.
So, um, so then,
you have to think about if you're going to commit your time, you know,
what is more meaningful to you, like,
or what was more worth to you, you know, so.
Yeah, awesome. Um, I think were kind
of [inaudible] now starting to get into repetitive questions around balancing work,
but is there anything else that you'd like to share about
your experiences as a remote student?
[LAUGHTER].
Oh, I guess in terms of balancing work,
I think that's always gonna be a challenge.
I mean, it's- there's always gonna be different challenges
at different points in time because these courses,
you know, span over years, right?
I mean, if you're really serious about doing like a- like a masters program, you know,
and you're talking about a couple of years, right,
before you- so you think you- you'll be in different points in life at that point.
So, I think, uh,
keeping your, I guess,
your goal centered to what you want and then you're looking at
life around that is- is- is what I do.
And, you know, it's- it's definitely hard, I mean,
I won't advertise anything here,
I mean, it takes a lot of commitment and sacrifice.
But I think at the end of the day,
if- if that's what you want,
you know, that's where your passion then you make it work.
Yeah.
Okay.
Dido. [LAUGHTER].
Dido? [LAUGHTER] Um, I actually have another question for you, guys.
Did you- I don't remember your program plans off the top of my head, um,
but did you guys take courses every quarter since
you've started or have you taken breaks or what does that look like?
I- I- I have taken,
yeah, I've taken a break.
So, I've taken courses, um,
for the first, um- so what I did was for the first two quarters,
I took it back to back and then, you know,
I had to switch my job so I took a break and then,
you know, arriving in my course.
So, yeah, taking a break.
Yeah. How about you?
I- I took break to meet-
take the classical prerequisite in the middle because in the beginning,
the courses do not require prerequisite,
um, to statistics and then into international security.
And then, I take a break about a year to take
all the calculus requirement and then computer programming requirement.
[NOISE] And I took MSE courses.
So, I've been taking maybe one to two classes a quarter
depending on the workload and there are resources available to find,
um, how hard or difficult of courses.
Uh, there's a Stanford student,
very smart guy created this website.
Carta?
Carta.
Yeah.
And that you can go there and then you can get
all the insights about the course and average grade.
And every time each students spend for
the course and- and you can kind of plan that, uh, according to the source.
Using that sometime I decide to take another coursework looking,
"Oh, this one takes one hour a week and this one takes one hour a week."
And like probably combined that in one quarter.
And another course it says,
three hours a week or four hours a week and I'll only take one.
So, um, there are ways that you can kinda plan it.
Yeah.
And there were resources available.
And again, just talking to other students and they- they will help you,
so take this course and take that course.
Yeah. And I can speak to that too.
We, um, employ a few current graduate students and some of
the higher enrollment departments like Management Science and Engineering,
Computer Science, Statistics and Electrical Engineering.
And we have course adviser emails on our website,
and you can email, you know,
EE course adviser directly and say, "Hey,
like I'm interested in this certificate or this specific course.
What is the workload look like,
what's a logical order to take the courses,
um, or this is my background what do you think? "
And they are so knowledgeable about this so they can give you
really really detailed- way better answers
than I could ever give about whether or not this makes sense for you.
Um, so that's definitely something that I recommend people utilize,
maybe before deciding on of course to enroll or, you know,
reach out to us and we'll- we'll loop them in if we think it makes sense.
Um, and then also just to reiterate what you guys have already touched on,
you don't have to take courses every quarter.
If you're pursuing a graduate certificate,
we give you three years from when you
finished your first course to finish your certificate.
So, it's a lot of time, usually,
certificates only require four courses,
so you can really take your time and take quarters off.
Um, and- and, you know, like you said,
use different resources, I don't think I'm allowed to sanction Carta, it's like,
you should check how many hours your [LAUGHTER] classes but,
I do know a lot of students use it, um,
and that can be a really helpful way to just plan around what's going on.
Also, if you, you know,
if you are in communication with your managers and- and maybe you guys
can speak to this more of your experience working with your manager through this.
You know, I talked to a lot of students where they,
you know, said, "Well, work project just randomly came up."
And- and sometimes that's unavoidable and you have to drop a class,
and- and we're there to help you through it,
but as much as you can communicate with your managers at your work and kind of know well.
Spring has a big project,
I won't take a course then.
Summer's going to be pretty quiet,
that's a great time for me to do something.
I think that's a great strategy to employ as well and I hope
you guys have specific examples of working with your manager,
whoever and it kind of has support through this program?
Yeah. No. I- I think I can talk to that.
So, like, for example, you know,
one of the things you have to plan is like some of
these courses are only offering a certain quarter.
Yes.
So, if you miss it in the last quarter and you know,
you miss it again then you just have one more year to do it.
So, that a little bit of planning needs to be done on your end.
But I think, um,
for me especially, you know,
during the first course, you know,
I specifically went up to my manager and said to him,
"I need your support here for this quarter.
I'm doing this, it's pretty intense course and,
you know, I may, you know,
requires some flexible work hours.
It's not that I'm not gonna do what you want me do.
I'm going to probably do more but, you know,
it just for need a support and, you know, helping me.
Maybe if I want to- you know,
maybe go out in an office hours during the workday."
And I think generally people are,
you know, I mean,
if your manager is a good manager, I mean,
they're- they're fine with it then, you know,
you can- you can walk around that.
But, yeah, I mean that's-
Yeah. Doing that as well?
I will because I- I was intentionally taking classes that's- were unrelated
to my work because- and so I was on my own. [LAUGHTER]
But you can still make it work.
Yeah.
Again, beca- because, I was doing that
because I was actually taking courses that I want to take.
I want something I wanna learn about.
So, you know, I actually wanted to make time,
commitment to make it work so.
Yeah, and, um, I'll just speak actually on a personal level.
I have not taken any courses through SCPD,
[LAUGHTER], I just work here [OVERLAPPING].
But I actually just started a part-time master's program myself,
um, and it's kinda on the weekends where I have to go to the class.
But even just doing that,
I've found that being honest with my team and with my manager and saying, "Hey.
This is what I'm doing, there's gonna be a day when I need to leave early to get to
class or just have a big thing due this week like."
You know and also setting that expectation for myself with school,
like I know there are certain weeks when enrollment is my main priority for this job,
and I kinda need to put my school work to the side.
[OVERLAPPING] So, I would say just setting those priorities with
yourself as much as you can before signing up is really important,
life will still hit you.
But I think, that's for my own personal experience, has been really helpful.
Um, and also to speak to course scheduling,
like you're talking about.
We- it tends to be that courses are
only offered once in the same quarter, each academic year,
which can be kinda frustrating,
depending on when you start in the year,
and you [OVERLAPPING] wanna be working through a certificate.
It's definitely something we're constantly trying to address, um,
because we are filling courses around campus,
we're kind of also at the whim of Stanford University scheduling.
Which- if you haven't worked in that,
it can be a pain [LAUGHTER].
So, you know, we're trying to make it as easy to work through as possible,
as many offerings, as consistently as possible.
And I think in the two years,
I've been here, we've definitely made improvements on that.
But, um, that is something to keep in mind,
and- and you're welcome again to reach out to us.
You can say, I'm interested in the certificate,
when are all the courses typically offered,
and we can kind of give you
a tentative idea of what a program plan might look like or, you know,
again it might give you a sense of
well spring quarter nothing and I'm gonna wanna take this offer,
that's a great quarter for me to take off.
You know, so we can- we can work with you,
and do our best to try and give you an idea,
and set an expectation of what your plan could look like.
Um, [NOISE] yeah.
And I think, you know, that's most of the questions that
we had- have had come through, I don't know.
There's anything else that you- if there have been an event like this before you started,
you would have wanted to have a question answered or.
It could have been great to attend an event like this before I started.
I think, um, [OVERLAPPING] a lot of what you learned through experience,
can be learn, you know, through some of these events, right?
So, can't think of any question that hasn't been yet [OVERLAPPING].
Hasn't been covered? [LAUGHTER].
Yet as [OVERLAPPING]. Yeah.
That's good. [LAUGHTER]
Yeah. What about you, do you everything, you wanna add?
Just one thing, I wanna say is, um, SCPD,
is ga- great resource and that administrators,
that, you know, has question, they answer.
And- but also the fact,
what is in TAs, are very helpful,
they are very accommodating.
And so, in some classes they offer alternate on assignments for enrolled students,
could they understand the challenges of the [inaudible] being remote student.
So, sometimes when, uh, full time student,
we're taking in classroom, uh,
test, they offer us to do like a writing assignment.
Um, so that it- it- it it's more flexible for us.
So, um, don't think that, you know,
yo- you know, you have to follow all the rules,
sometimes they- they're, I think,
sometime they're more lenient towards enrolled students
because it is more challenging. So.
Yeah. Awesome. Thank you for sharing that [OVERLAPPING].
Um, and just one other thing I'll note,
you know, we're wrapping up our session.
Thank you guys again for being here and answering all these questions.
Um, winter quarter enrollment is open.
So, if, you know, you liked what you've heard,
and you're interested in learning more,
and maybe even taking a course.
Our enrollment period is currently open until December 10th.
The actual quarter will start in January seventh,
and run till about mid,
end of March, depending on when finals are [NOISE].
Um, we have a lot of different courses that are being offered, um,
in a variety of departments,
not just the ones we've talked about tonight.
So, please, you know,
go on to scpd.stanford.edu.,
take a look at our portfolio.
Um, please reach out to us with any questions.
Um, for those of you remote,
there was a few slides that were posted at the beginning
that kind of reiterated this enrollment information.
Um, and for those of you that are here, you know,
feel free to come and talk to me, um,
about any questions you may have,
and- and if you guys are here for a few more minutes,
we can take, you know, some more direct questions. Um, but yeah.
Thank you guys so much for coming and for those online,
you know, thank you for- for listening and trying this experiment out with us.
Um, hopefully it's been helpful and given you idea of what taking a lecture,
there's lectures in this court- in this room all the time.
So, this is actually just what it's like.
I think there's a question there.
Oh, there's a question? Yeah.
[NOISE] Number one, regarding the, uh,
access to TA, and the lecture,
and versus what gone here.
Could you go to the classroom and take [inaudible] or,
you had to go to switches TV,
and ask your questions that- that we're pretty more than obviously if
you're going to access it but it's, uh, right- right?
That is one question and then my next questions is regarding the [inaudible] notes,
uh, I mean, uh,
I don't ask notes is that as you mentioned that,
you're taking in notes then post it there [inaudible].
But I just wanted to know,
it's very-very important that if I have access to your notes,
and I want to read [inaudible] then in order to be able to get a bit [inaudible] shares.
I- I'll just reiterate the questions for people online.
So, the first one, I think goes around just,
can you only talk to your TA,
or how- who do you get to interact with and how, is that the question?
What I meant was that versus what,
[inaudible] on campus [OVERLAPPING].
Oh yeah.
Or a- access to the campus,
can they go to the lecture itself live,
and there're two TA?
Yeah. I- so, I can speak to that.
So, you're asking about, can I attend the lecture on campus?
So, those seats are reserved for matriculated students and that being inside,
you can come to campus for office hours.
So, if you know there's an on-campus office hour happening and you're in the area,
please feel free to come.
Um, and also, you know, you can reach out to the teaching teams and if,
they have their own kinda like by appointment office hours,
again, they're more than willing to accommodate.
And then I think your second question was around access to textbook materials into notes?
And maybe, [OVERLAPPING] you guys can speak to that. Yeah.
I think just a point to the first question.
I think the other thing is, you know,
it's part of your curriculum, you know,
may- if you're doing a project which lasts the, uh,
entirety of the quarter, or at least three-fourths of the quarter,
your- you're assign like a,
like an adviser of that pro- project itself.
Oh, yeah.
So, you work with some- some TA, you know.
So, I think that can be a point for reference for, you know,
not just the problem but you can ask questions,
and they're pretty open to answer those.
And although, SCPD has its own office hours,
but I've never felt that you cannot go to another office hours.
Always been into just any office hours [LAUGHTER] that's on the calendar.
So, an- and I've been welcome.
So, that's- that's definitely been,
I'm not taken classes here because I think it's just easier for me to be- do it remotely.
Yeah.
Uh, but and then also, you know,
I think they're some logistics there.
Um but for the second question, I think,
um, as part of every lecture,
uh there's a material that's posted on the course website,
which includes the slide deck for that lecture,
notes for that lecture, and, you know,
even link to the video, and assignments around that good stuff.
So, I think between the three of those resources,
it's pretty detailed as to, you know,
I guess, what is covered in that particular lecture.
But I think, to your point, um, there's still,
you know, there may be some still details there may not be captured in those notes.
So, I think for that, I- I prefer to just stick my own notes and, you know,
cross-reference that more importantly with fellow, um, class- classmates.
Yeah. And they're open to sharing their notes as well. So, and that's good.
Anything you wanna add or?
As far as coming to class in person,
just ask because I- I think to classroom where it was for.
So, they let you know, that, you know,
they're really le- let you know in advance that this full,
and there's no room.
But lot of time there're- when there's room TA will say,
just- you're more than welcome to come. So good.
But I always ask- I always ask,
well can I come to this class for this session,
and never got no for an answer.
The- they always said, yes.
So, but certain class,
they will let you know in ahead time,
they're- they're short with, um seating.
And as far as office hours, again just ask,
they know that you're working professional,
and yet challenging, and sometimes a lot of people are in different time zone.
So, um, if there's something they can accommodate, they would try to do it.
An- and a lot of the TAs are students, just like us.
So, they'll try to work with you.
That's right.
Uh, so one of the things that they've been
started doing is the Google Hangout, um, and Skype.
So- but if you have other medium that you wanna use,
you can- all you have to just ask.
Yeah. Yeah. Awesome. Well, I think that concludes our panel, or Q and A.
Thank you guys so much.
And I'm gonna wave,
so they know that we're no longer recording [LAUGHTER]. This is event.